okay today I'm going to talk to you
about strong and weak acids we're gonna
see what makes a strong acid what makes
a weak acid we're going to look at
concentration and how that relates to
this and finally we gonna have a look at
the pH scale and see how hydrogen ion
concentration works in that as well so
first of all let's think about what is
an acid so acid is a measure of hydrogen
ion concentration the greater the
concentration of hydrogen ions the
stronger the acid so strong acids the
reason why we call them strong acids is
when they're in solution they fully
ionized now what that means is they're
completely or nearly completely break
down to form to form their ions I'll
show you what I mean by this so for
example hydrochloric acid is an example
of a strong acid it consists of hydrogen
and chloride ions so in solution this
fully ionized is to produce H+ ions and
Cl minus ions so remember it's this H+
the this that means that it's an acid
this hydrogen ion concentration another
example would be nitric acid which is
made of hydrogen ions and nitrate ions
that also completely dissociates to form
these products here so you see both of
them completely dissociate now we'll
have a look in comparison in just a
minute because I figured important to
have a look at weak acids now weak acids
don't fully ionized in solution they
partially ionized now the good example
is ethanoic acid also known as vinegar
so you'll notice the big difference is
again we have a hydrogen ion being
formed but this here is a reversible
reaction which means it doesn't fully
dissociate meaning that if meaning that
will have fewer hydrogen ions as a
result because the reaction can go this
way or this way because
we have an equilibrium so that's how
weak acids are different they don't
fully ionized so strong acids tend to
have a lower pH than weak acids for
example around zero to two whereas weak
acids usually have a pH a little bit
higher of two to six because they're
less good at giving up those hydrogen
ions into solution so how we describe
that is whether or not they fully
ionized so as you can see here because
we don't have a reversible reaction
arrow we just have this hydrogen
chlorine breaking down to form these two
ions or just allowing these ions to be
free in solution whereas these ones
because it's a reversible reaction we
can also have more ethanoic acid being
formed which would mean a lower
concentration of hydrogen ions so these
ones partially ionized now we can't get
these confused with concentrated because
you can have it's a low concentration
strong acid or a highly concentrated
weak acid so let's just imagine I've got
a big beaker here containing I don't
know 1 decimeter cubed of of water and
in it we have we've had some HCl which
has fully dissociated so this would be
like a low concentration but a strong
acid so we're still going to have every
single acid molecule giving up its
hydrogen ion but it's a low
concentration there's not many of those
HCL's full-stop whereas let's imagine if
I had a concentrated solution of
ethanoic acid so still each one of these
ethanoic acid molecules isn't going to
fully dissociate it's going to partha
kind of partially associate or partially
ionized but which gives us this here
which is a a high concentration of a
weak acid so concentration and strength
of acid aren't exactly the same things
now the only last thing I'm going to
show you is how the pH scale works
because let's say remember pH scale is a
measure of hydrogen ion
concentration so let's say a particular
substance has a pH of 4 let's say for
that particular substance there's 0.001
most pedesta meter cubed of that
substance
now to get to ph 3 it's a scale where we
need to times by 10 so there's 10 times
the concentration of acid molecules to
go from ph 4 to ph 3 so this would have
0.01 molar per decimeter cubed to get to
ph 3 ph 2 the same again
they'd have a concentration of 0.1 moles
per decimeter cubed and to get to ph 1
again it's the same thing so ph 1 of
this substance would have 1 moles per
decimeter cubed of those of those acid
molecules now to go the other way
it's a pH 5 you just divide by 10
instead so if I want to go from PAH for
two periods five what's the
concentration going to be it's going to
be 0.0001 moles per decimeter cubed that
is how acids strong acids and weak acids
work that is how the pH scale works
thank you very much